The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
YEN-JIE LEE: OK, so
welcome back to 803.
Happy to see you again.
So today, we are going to
continue our discussion
of dispersive medium.
And there are two
questions we are
going to ask in
this lecture, and we
will answer also these two
questions in this lecture.
So just to warn you in
advance, this lecture
will have a lot of mathematics,
so fasten the seatbelt
and follow me.
And stop me any time
you don't feel like you
know you understand something.
So let's get started.
OK, so today, we are going
to talk about phenomena
related to dispersion.
And last time, we
started a discussion
about how to send
information from one
place to the other place right.
So what we should be before
was to send square pulse.
So if I do have a machine which
can produce a square pulse,
then I can define
something like this.
So over some ratio,
which I set, I
can actually separate 0 and 1.
So if I have a pulse
which is actually
having an amplitude greater
than some threshold and I say,
OK, I've got 1, and
if it's actually
below some straight line,
say, OK, I've got a 0.
And with that way, we
actually can send information
from one place to
the other place.
So that sounds really nice.
However, if we work on
a dispersive medium,
which is really very common--
for example, light
and gas is actually--
not all the lights with
different wavelengths are
traveling at the
same speed, and also,
as you've seen before in
the p-set, deep water,
and also the strings,
considering a realistic string
with stiffness, et
cetera, et cetera--
to the wavelength of the
input wave is going to affect
the speed of this
travelling wave.
So in short, the speed
of the wave propagation
in a dispersive medium will
depend on the wavelengths
of this wave.
So that brings us
a lot of trouble
because, for example, here we
are trying to send a Gaussian
pulse through the
medium, but after a while
this pulse actually becomes
wider and wider because
of the dispersion.
Because all the components
with different wavelengths
which actually construct
this narrow pulse,
actually are traveling
at different speeds.
Therefore, if you
wait long enough,
all the different frequencies,
or all the different frequency
harmonic waves are travel
at different speeds,
therefore you get
the, dispersion,
which results in a much
wider pulse in the end.
And at some point,
this pulse is going
to be really wide,
such that it's actually
going to be very difficult
to separate 0 from 1.
So that's the problem.
And we also did some
simulations with computer.
We do see this behavior also
in our computer simulation.
If I put in triangular pulse
and allow it to evolve,
and like what we did
before, we assume
that there's a stiffness
in this string system.
And you will see that,
OK, as a function of time,
this part is now longer
a triangular shape,
but you have a very
complicated structure.
So that is actually
a problem we are
going to try to solve today.
And during that discussion
last time, in the lecture,
we also introduced dispersion
relation omega k and also tried
to overlap two travelling
waves with similar wavelengths.
And that would give
you beat phenomenon.
That probably doesn't
surprise you any more.
As you can see
from this example,
you have the beat
phenomenon, and you
can see the amplitude is
actually variating slowly,
the function of position.
And if you follow the red
point, which is actually
associated with one of the
peak, in the structure called
carrier, OK, it's
actually moving
at the phase velocity, the P,
which we introduced last time.
The formula for BP, which is
actually the speed of harmonic,
oscillating travelling wave is
actually defined as vp equal
to omega over k,
and the green point,
which actually always at the
minima of the distribution,
which is actually associated
with the speed of the envelope.
You can see that,
indeed, it actually
can move at different speeds.
It depends on the
dispersion relation omega
as a function of k you
have in this system.
And we call the speed
of these envelope,
which we construct from these
two overlapping travelling
waves to be--
we call it group velocity.
And the definition
of group velocity
is vg equal to d omega dk.
So that's what we have
learned last time.
OK, you may ask, OK, what
do I mean by group velocity?
And can I use it
beyond what we have
done for the beat phenomena.
But what do I mean
by group velocity?
Is that really useful,
and it's actually
which part of the structure
I was talking about.
So in that case of two
overlapping progressing waves
with similar length
or similar frequency,
when we see that the
group velocity actually
present the speed of
the envelope, right?
Can we actually
learn something more
general about group velocity?
The second question
which we are asking
is, OK, now we have this
problem of dispersion.
This square pulse is going to
be something which is really
wide after some period of time.
So that's clearly a problem,
and how do we actually
solve this problem, and how do
we actually send information
like, for example, music
over a large distance
from one place to another place.
So that's essentially
what we're going
to try to understand today.
So let's start with an
infinitely long string.
And this string is actually very
long, and this began from here,
and it goes to some place which
is really, really far away.
And, of course, as
usually, I can actually
hold one end of this
string and shake it a bit,
then I can actually
create some kind of pulse
which is going to
travel along this string
towards a positive x direction.
In this case, I defined
the x coordinate
will be pointing to a
right hand side, and thus
the positive direction.
So of course I can hold this
string, and I just shake it,
and I would prepare a pulse
on this medium, which is
a string with constant tension.
So I can describe the motion--
you can describe the motion of
Yen-Jie's hand by a function.
So you can say, OK, Yen-Jie is
somehow doing a really nice job
and oscillating at
constant frequency.
Like I can say, OK, Yen-Jie
is shaking this thing
to produce a harmonic
wave, for example.
And that, I can actually
describe the motion of the hand
by f of t.
That's very good.
And from what we have
learned in the last lecture,
we've found that,
basically, waves,
harmonic waves with
different frequency,
or with different
wavelengths, are
traveling at different speeds.
Therefore, we would like to
actually decompose the motion
of Yen-Jie's hand into
many, many harmonic waves--
then attack them one by one,
to follow them one by one,
then I can solve this problem.
So that's actually what
we are going to do.
And that will involve some
math, which we would follow
from the math department.
And before that, I would like to
introduce the imitation first.
As I said f of t is
actually the displacement
as a function of time
as x is equal to 0.
So basically, I'm
holding this string,
and I move things up and
down, so that, actually, I
move this string away from the
equilibrium positive, which
is actually y equal to 0.
Then what is going to happen?
What is going to
happen is that I'm
going to produce
some kind of pulse,
and this pulse, I can
actually describe it
by a function, which
is psi x and p,
this psi is actually
describing the displacement
as a function of x,
and as a function of t.
Apparently, if you
put x equals to zero,
then you go back
to f of t, right?
Basically that's the idea.
OK.
So what we have learned
before we introduce
dispersive medium is that, if
I have a non-dispersive medium,
OK, if I have a
non-dispersive medium,
then things are pretty
simple because omega over K
is actually a constant, which
is the phase velocity, vp.
And omega is actually
just equal to vp times k.
That means, no matter
what kind of wavelength
we are talking about, no matter
what kind of angular frequency
we are talking about,
harmonic progressing wave
is going to travel
at the speed of Vp.
No matter what's the frequency,
or what's the wavelength.
So that makes our
life much simpler
when we work on
non-dispersive medium.
In this case, if I have
a non-dispersive medium,
then psi would be equal to--
maybe I write it here--
if I have non-dispersive
medium where,
no matter what
kind of frequency,
the speed of the
harmonic traveling wave
is a constant, which is actually
Vp, I can write down psi
x t to could be equal to
f of t minus x over v.
Just remember f is
actually describing
how I shake one
end of the string,
and, basically you
can see that ha!
What is happening is
that my hand is actually
generating the shape of the
pulse as a function of x,
as a function of
time, and it can
be described by a really
simple formula here.
So this is actually really
nice for non-dispersive.
As I introduced before, when we
talk about dispersive medium,
then, if I go to
dispersive, omega
is actually a function of k, and
can be a non-linear function.
So what does that mean?
That means, if I evaluate
vp, which is actually
the phase velocity, which
is the formula there,
this is going to be
omega of k divided by k.
That means BP is going
to be a function of k,
the wavelength-- wave number.
It's not going to be a
constant in general--
unless omega is actually
equal to vp times k,
in general, vp can
actually be some quantity
which is variating
as a function of k.
OK?
Then we have trouble
because that means,
when I produce progressing wave
from the left hand side end,
it's actually made of
many, many harmonic waves,
right, with different
angular frequency.
So I can shake this like
[MAKES NOISE],, different speed.
And I can always decompose
the motion of Yen-Jie's hand
into many, many harmonic waves.
The problem is, all those
harmonic waves are going to be
travelling at different speed.
How do we actually
describe this?
So that's the trouble.
And I was really frustrated
when I think about this problem,
and my friend from
the math department
said, hey, we have solved
this problem a long time ago.
[LAUGHTER]
So this is not the
problem anymore.
And I say, oh, what is the
idea you're talking about?
And they actually
told me that you
should use Fourier transform
to attack this problem.
OK?
This is the idea.
The idea is that I
can now write down
f of t, which is motion
of Yen-Jie's hand,
and this can even returned
as a superposition
of infinite number of waves.
I can integrate
from minus infinity
to infinity, t omega, which
is the angular frequency.
And each contributing wave
has an amplitutde associated
with it, which is, as you
see, is a function omega.
And the actual wave is
actually written in terms
of exponential minus i omega t.
So now, let's actually you look
at this thing really carefully.
What am I doing?
I am saying that I, now, can
shake one end of the string up
and down according to my will.
And, if I do this
for a long time,
I can actually describe
the motion of my hand
by infinite number of harmonic
waves, which is actually
kind of like
exponential i omega t
describing the frequency of
these waves, and each of them
got associated amplitude.
And you may ask,
OK, wait a second,
you call this Fourier transform,
and I have learned that before,
but I learned a
different version.
I learned a version
of cosine and sine?
And what is going on?
Actually, they are all the same.
No matter what you
do, you can actually
also do that with
cosine and sine,
but what I actually found
is that it's actually easier
to deal with exponential
functional form
You can always write
exponential i omega
t in terms of sine and
cosine and absorb the i
into a c omega.
Basically, these things are
identical between these two
forms of this answer.
So therefore, in
this lecture, I'm
going to stick with
this functional form.
OK, any questions?
STUDENT: We don't include
dx in the [INAUDIBLE]??
YEN-JIE LEE: Not yet.
We are going to include that.
Because, for that, in
order to actually--
OK, so now I actually
decompose the motion of my hand
into many, many waves--
which should be or is say
it many, many oscillation
with different frequencies.
So I actually
describe the motion
of my hand infinite
number of oscillation
with different frequency.
And the trouble we are facing is
that all those oscillations are
going to be charged
travelling at different speeds
because of the
dispersion relation.
Therefore, what I am
going to do afterwards
is to show you that, OK, I can
write down the functional form
for psi in this general case.
So for that, that's actually
what I'm going to do now.
So now, I would like to know
what would be the psi xt, which
actually the position of the
string as a function of x,
and at some specific
time equal to t.
And that can be written as, I
do the an integration from minus
infinity to infinity
over frequency omega,
and I have the usual
amplitude associated
with the angular
frequency omega,
and the exponential i omega t--
minus i omega t because that's
the convention I'm using here--
and I say, OK, plus ik,
which is a function omega--
x.
So now you can to
see that what I'm
doing here is that I
am now progressing,
I am making infinite number
of progressing waves.
Each of these
exponential functions
is a progressing wave with
angular frequency omega.
And why do I write k as a
function of omega x here?
It's because they are going
to be travelling at the speed
of omega over k.
Therefore, I need to
actually put k here,
and this k is actually--
this k is actually not
the independent parameter.
It's actually a
function of omega.
So we can see that, here, we
do an integration over omega
from minus infinity
to infinity--
for each omega you can actually
find the corresponding k,
right?
Because of the
dispersion relation.
Because omega is
a function of k,
therefore you can always solve
the corresponding k, right?
Then you put it there?
Because you are now
trying to propagate
how many waves with
different angular
frequency at different speed--
then we are done.
That looks like a
wonderful solution,
and we can actually see how
it works for our purpose.
Any questions?
All right.
So that's really nice.
And I can now do a
really simple test
to see if this really works.
Let me try a very simple case.
OK, a spatial case.
If I now go back to
use this description
to describe non-dispersive
medium and see what
will happen.
Now my k as a function omega
is actually rather simple.
It's actually omega over vp--
according to the
dispersion relation here.
I can solve k, as
I was mentioning,
with these dispersion
relation formula.
And then I can conclude
k as a function
omega is omega over vp.
Then I can now put that
into this equation,
and I'm going to
get psi x of t--
this would be equal
to minus infinity
to infinity d omega, c omega,
exponential minus i omega
t minus omega over vx.
And we can actually take omega
out of this, minus infinity
to infinity d omega c omega
exponential minus i omega
t minus x divided by v. And
you can see that, huh, indeed,
this is actually ft
minus x over v. OK.
I'm dropping the vp here.
This should be vp
all over the place.
So you can see that, now, if I
have solved the k as a function
omega, and I plug it in
in this special case,
which is non-dispersive medium,
omega over k equal to vp,
then I really calculate
this integral,
then I can quickly
identify that--
huh, I can write the
functional form in this way.
And this is actually
really familiar to me
because that's actually using
this definition, f is actually
equal to integration minus
infinity to infinity, d omega,
c omega, exponential
minus i omega t.
If I replace t, by t minus
x over vp, then I'm done.
So I have evaluated this
integration, which is actually
just f t minus x over vp.
So that's exactly what
guessed from the beginning.
So if I have a
non-dispersive medium,
then psi xt will be
equal to this function.
So that gives us some
kind of confidence that,
OK, at the easy case, it works.
All right, so that's very
nice, all sounds very good.
But wait a second.
How do I actually
extract this c,
which is a function of omega?
I'm troubled because this
is an infinite integral from
minus infinity to infinity.
And that means I have infinite
number of constants, which I
have to determine the c omega.
How do I actually do this?
So that is another
point which I would
like to discuss before
we actually go ahead
and really use this function
for the dispersive medium case.
So how to we actually extract
c as a function of omega?
So for that, we really
need to employ a few uses
for formula, which are
actually documented here.
How many of you actually have
not heard about delta function
before?
OK, a few of you actually have
not heard about delta function.
So what is actually
your delta function?
This is a delta function.
So a delta function
is actually a notation
which actually shows
you a function, which
is should only be non-zero,
at x equal to zero.
And the x equal to zero,
the size of this function
as you're going to infinity,
and on the other hand,
all the other points
at x not equal to zero,
the delta function
is equal to zero.
So that's actually the kind of
function I was talking about.
And the area of this function,
if you're doing the equation
over minus infinity
infinity over x,
the integration of these delta
m the area is actually 1.
So that is actually
the kind of function.
So essentially, it's a really,
really narrow function, OK,
very narrow, very
narrow, very narrow.
But the area is
finite, which is why.
So you can have a square.
You can actually start
with a square pulse,
or square function,
and you can actually
make the width of the square
narrower, smaller and smaller
and smaller, go to 0.
Then what you are going
to get is essentially
the delta function.
That's actually how we
understand this delta function.
All right, really quickly.
And also, we would like
to use a few formula which
are documented here.
So if I do an integration from
minus infinity to infinity,
exponential i omega
minus omega prime,
t over the t which is
integrating over time, t, here.
And then divide the whole
formula by 1 and over 2pi.
What I'm going to get
is a delta function,
which is a delta function which
is omega minus omega prime.
So that means when this delta
function formula tells us
that omega is equal
to omega prime,
then this function is
actually going to infinity.
And only when omega
equal to omega prime,
this function is not zero.
Any other place, this
function is always zero.
And this strange
integration should give you
this delta function.
So that's the first
thing which we will use,
was one useful formula.
The second thing which
what just I talked about,
if I do an integration over
minus infinity to infinity,
delta x dx, then
basically you get 1.
The third one is actually
kind of interesting.
Let's take a look.
So if I do an integration
over from minus infinity
to infinity, delta
function x minus alpha.
Let's look at this
delta function first.
This function is only non-zero
when x is equal to what?
AUDIENCE: Alpha.
YEN-JIE LEE: Yeah.
When x is equal to alpha,
only when that happen,
this is actually non-zero.
If you multiply this delta
function to some function which
is f of alpha, and integrate
over alpha from minus
infinity to infinity.
And that means
that when alpha is
equal to x, or x equal to
alpha, this integration
give you non-zero result.
All the other ways,
you will get zero.
The interesting thing is that
if you do this integration, what
you are going to get is that
OK, when I integrate over alpha,
only when alpha is equal to
x this thing is non-zero.
Therefore what you
are going to get
is, you get only one point of
the width, which is actually
f of x.
So that's the intuition
about this formula.
That's just fine.
Any questions related
to those formulas?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
YEN-JIE LEE: Hm?
YEN-JIE LEE: Yeah, this is
actually pretty complicated,
so it would take a few 10,
20 minutes to explain that.
But let's just take the words
from the math department--
we trust them.
All right, so once I
have those formula,
I can now demonstrate
you how I can actually
track C as a function omega.
So this is actually
the goal, right?
So don't forget why we are
doing what we are doing,
is to try to extract what
is actually the C omega,
so that we can actually
finish this formula.
So how do we do that?
So suppose, if I evaluate this.
This function, 1 over
2pi, minus infinity
to infinity dt, ft,
exponential i omega t.
If I evaluate this function.
This is coming out
of nowhere, right?
So coming out of Yen-Jie's
hand, maybe, I don't know.
Suppose if I evaluate
this function,
and now I have ft here, right?
I can replace ft by these
interesting formula.
If I do that, then basically I
get 1 over 2pi minus infinity
to infinity dt, minus
infinity infinity C omega
prime, exponential
minus i omega prime t.
And the last is actually
integrating over d omega prime.
So this is actually the f of t.
This is actually f of t.
I'm just replacing that
formula into this integral.
And then I have the rest,
which is exponential i omega t.
And of course, I can
continue and collect
all the relevant terms together.
This is actually equal to 1 over
2i, minus infinity to infinity.
I collect all the terms related
to omega prime to the left hand
side.
Basically what I get is C
omega prime d omega prime.
This is actually coming
from here, except--
yeah, OK, it is actually
coming from here.
And I have another integral
which is from minus infinity
to infinity, this time
integrating over delta dt.
And I have dt here, exponential
i omega minus omega prime t.
So basically I'm collecting
these two terms together.
They now become exponential
i omega minus omega prime t.
So basically, no magic happened,
but I'm just re-writing things
and we are arranging things from
this formula to that formula.
Then if we look at this
formula, this formula here,
and the formula sheet we have.
1 over 2pi minus
infinity to infinity
to this integration over
t, exponential i omega
minus omega prime t.
That will give you
delta function,
which is delta omega
minus omega prime.
Therefore, I can continue
this calculation here.
Thus it's going to give you
minus infinity to infinity.
I identify this part,
this part, and this part,
to be the delta function.
Therefore, what I get is
minus infinity to infinity, C
omega prime, delta omega minus
omega prime, d omega prime.
Am I going too fast?
Everybody's following?
So you can see that
what we have been doing,
I use this formula
coming out of nowhere.
I replace f by the formula
I was writing there.
And then I collect the
terms I like together.
That's all I did.
And then I found, aha!
One part of the formula is
actually the delta function.
Then I put the delta
a function here.
And then finally, I use
the third formula here,
which I have related to delta
function, and I found, aha!
If I do this
integration, I know how
to do this integration
even without knowing
the structure of C. This
is actually just changing
the omega prime to omega.
So that's actually what this
integration actually does.
Therefore, I get C omega.
Look at what we have done.
What we have done is
that, we have proof
that this formula
coming out of nowhere,
to be a continuous
version of mode picker.
You remember the fourth
year decomposition before?
You were using the orthogonality
of the sine function,
and I can do some kind
of fancy integration
to actually extract
a m from one of the--
which is associated with one
of the normal mode, right?
What we are doing here is
actually a continuous version.
Now omega is
actually continuous.
And I'm now using
the orthogonality
of the exponential function.
If I do this integration,
that will only
give you non-zero value when
omega is equal to omega prime.
It's exactly the
same thing, right?
Then I can construct an
integration like this.
And now will give
you the redoubting C
as a function omega, which
is like the amplitude of one
of the associated harmonics
exponential i omega t.
So in short, from
this exercise, we
have shown you
that C of omega can
be extracted using this formula
1 over 2pi, minus infinity
to infinity dt, f of t,
exponential i omega t.
That's actually how we
actually can determine
all the amplitude associated
to a specific exponential
function.
Any questions so far?
OK, so if no question, then
we can actually continue.
So let's actually go back
to the original question,
which we were posting.
So we have a problem
related to the transmission
of information.
So this is actually
where we got started.
If I send a square pulse
on a dispersive median,
then I have some
trouble, which is
that this pulse is going
to disperse and become
wider and wider.
It's changing as a
function of time,
as a function of
distance it travel.
That's not cool.
All right, so therefore what
I am going to do is this.
There was a very
smart idea which
were discovered long time
ago, during maybe World War I,
and widely used in World War
II, which is the AM radio.
What is AM?
Is actually amplitude
modulation radio.
This smart idea
is the following.
I will describe it
before we take a break.
So this smart idea, AM
radio is the following.
If I have some kind of
information which is fs t.
s here means signal.
If I have some
kind of information
I would like to
send, I can send it
by oscillating one
end of the string.
And this is what I want to send.
And there are two ways you
can send this fs function.
The first one is actually what
did before, I send it directly.
I just said OK, if I want
to send this function,
then I just oscillate
the string according
to the functional form.
Yen-Jie just have to be
really careful, right?
So that you can
send this function.
And that fails miserably.
Why?
Because all the components
which actually produce the fs,
in this case the square pulse,
all those components are
travelling at different speed.
Therefore, the information
will never get there,
because of the dispersion.
So now what should
we do instead?
Instead of doing sending fs
as a function of t directly,
what you could do
is that I can now
send f of t, which is equal
to f of s t cosine omega0t.
Where omega0 is a very,
very large number.
And basically, look at
what we have been doing.
So that means I, instead
of sending fs directly,
I send fs, but modulated
by a really high frequency
function, cosine omega0t.
And this will work.
And you will only know
that after we come back
from the break, which
is twenty first.
Let's take five minute break.
And if you have any questions,
you can actually ask me here.
So we will continue the
discussion about AM radio.
So before the break, actually
we introduced this one
possible solution to solve
this dispersive median problem,
is that I can now actually send
instead of fs as a function
t, which is actually the
signal I want to send,
I could send fs, but
multiplied by cosine omega0t.
If I assume that fs is
some really slow function,
slowly varying as
a function of time,
compared to cosine omega0t.
Cosine omega0t is a
really fast function,
oscillating up and down
like crazy, really fast.
If I multiply fs
by this function,
what is going to happen?
We are going to show
you that actually that
means I am going to
only have non-zero C
function, or a large
contribution of C,
in a very thin middle
range of omega.
So we'll show that.
So in a typical case, fs is
really slow, which is like,
for example, my
sound, et cetera,
in the label of one kilohertz.
And you can actually
design a system
which will actually multiply
this fs by cosine omega0t.
Omega0 can be as fast
as 1.1 to 30 megahertz.
If you do this
calculation, then you
will find that OK, the range
of omega, with sizable C omega
is small.
It's roughly equal to
omega0 minus omega s,
to omega0 plus omega
s, where omega s is
the typical frequency
in your signal.
And the omega0 is the
typical frequency of--
the frequency of
your cosine omega t
term, which is
actually, later, you
will recognize this as carrier.
So what I want to say is
that if I do this trick,
what is going to happen
is that the range
of omega, which you have sizable
contribution from C omega--
C omega is the
associated amplitude,
associated amplitude.
It's going to be confined
to a really small region
from omega0 minus omega
s, to omega0 plus omega s.
So that's the trick which
actually makes this problem
solvable.
How do we know this?
That is because, if
I now, for example, I
send fs equal to
cosine omega st.
If this is actually the signal
which I would like to send,
just a harmonic wave, then
what is going to happen
is that I'm going to get ft
is equal to cosine omega st
cosine--
so this is actually
multiplied by cosine omega0t.
So I have cosine omega0t here.
I have cosine
multiplied by cosine.
Therefore I have
the question which
I prepare here, the formula,
of cosine alpha times
cosine beta will be equal
to the functional form.
There's a remainder,
therefore I can now
write it as 1 over
2 cosine omega s
minus omega0 t plus cosine
omega s plus omega0.
You can see that when I actually
multiply two cosine functions
together, then what I get is
actually the omega0 minus omega
s.
You can actually put the minus
sign there, it didn't matter.
And cosine omega0
plus omega s times t.
So therefore, you can see that
the frequency, there are only
two frequencies which contribute
to this C of omega, which is
actually these two frequencies.
So that is actually why,
if you do this trick,
you actually try to modulate
your slow signal function
by a fast carrier frequency.
Then you are going to confine
the effective range of omega
into a very small range.
Why is that useful?
That's actually what I
want to answer to you.
Suppose I have this crazy
dispersion relation, which
is omega as a function
of K. You can graph it,
and suppose it looks
really crazy like this.
And if I set my carrier
oscillation frequency
to be omega0, and that will
give you a corresponding wave
number which is K0.
I hope you can see it.
That's the corresponding K0.
Before we actually multiply this
function, it's a slow function.
It's not exactly
one cosine function.
So if you just have a cosine
function harmonic wave,
then you don't really
need this trick,
because it's
actually going to be
traveling at a speed
of some constant speed.
It's a harmonic traveling wave.
But if this is actually
a slow function, but not
really a single harmonic wave,
then what is going to happen
is that you are going to need a
wide range of K value or omega
value to describe fs.
Then you are in
trouble because now,
all the waves with different
wavelengths are going to be
travelling at different speed.
Then you have this
dispersion problem.
On the other hand, if I
multiply this function,
this slow function, by a
fast oscillating function,
I am confining the
effective range of omega
into this small box,
which is actually
between omega0 minus
or plus omega s.
This is actually omega0
plus minus omega s.
This is actually the range
of the possible omega,
which contribute to
this resulting f of t.
Therefore, the behavior
of this function
is actually much
easier to understand.
So with that given
there, suppose now I have
a large difference between--
suppose I have a large
difference between omega s
and omega0.
Then I can actually focus
on a very small range
in this dispersion
relation diagram.
Then I can write omega
as a function of K,
the dispersion relation
equal to omega0 plus K
minus K0, partial omega,
partial K. Evaluate
it at a equal to K0,
plus higher order term.
Basically I can do
this Taylor expansion.
And maybe it surprised you, you
can immediately identify, ha!
This is delta d omega dk,
is the group velocity.
Suddenly it show up in
the Taylor expansion
of the dispersion relation.
so if I focus on the region
which is around omega0,
then I can actually re-write
omega in this functional form.
Omega is actually
equal to omega0 plus K
minus K0 times Vg, which
is the group velocity.
Suppose this is happening,
then now I can actually
go ahead and really calculate
the functional form for f of t.
So suppose I have
this definition of t.
The definition of t is equal
to fs t times cosine omega0t.
Or say I can actually
write it in a complex form,
instead of writing it in a
cosine omega0t functional form,
I can write it in
exponential functional form.
Exponential minus i omega0t,
which is actually more
convenient for the discussion.
So what is going to happen if
I actually do this calculation?
Then basically that's
one example signal
which I would like to
send on the slides.
So if I am trying to send a
progressing harmonic wave,
then after multiplying by
this exponential i omega0t
function, or a cosine
function, basically
you get something which is
actually oscillating really
fast, which is actually
the AM signal we are trying
to send through this media.
So we can actually
identify, this
is actually the structure of
this, actually the carrier.
And this signal
become the analogue,
in analogy to what we actually
have discussed for that beat
phenomenon case.
So now, if the omega
range is really small,
then I can actually
write this down.
Write a functional form of
omega in this functional form.
Or I can actually
take out the kVg term,
and the rest is actually
going to be something
like some constant a, where
a is actually equal to omega0
minus Vg times K0.
So basically I'm just
taking out this K term here,
and this become this term.
With this formula,
I can solve what
would be the
functional form for K,
as a preparation for what
I'm going to do later.
So K can be also expressed
as omega over Vg.
So basically I just
solve the K plus b.
b is actually just
some constant.
Just do it for
convenience, I can
write b equal to K0 minus
omega0 divided by Vg.
What we learned here is that
if the range of effective omega
is really small
around omega zero,
then the relation
between omega and the K
becomes a linear function.
Of course, it's still not like
the case for the non dispersive
median, where omega
over K is a constant.
But at least it becomes
a linear function,
which is actually much nicer.
So finally, with all those
preparation we have done,
we would like to show one
important consequence.
So what we are trying to
do is to show that psi xt.
Now I send, I
oscillate the median,
the string, by this f of
t, which I designed there.
ft is actually fs times
exponential i omega0t.
That's actually designed there.
I would like to show that
the resulting amplitude will
be equal to fs t minus x divided
by Vg, exponential minus i
omega0t minus K0x.
Of course I need to take
the real part of this
in, to go back to the real axis.
Basically I dropped the i
sine omega t contribution.
So this is actually
what I want to show.
Before I go through
all those math,
let's do get the conclusion
which we would like to draw,
before we actually really
go through the math.
The conclusion which I would
like to draw is that, OK,
this is actually my analogue.
My analogue is going to be
travelling at the speed of Vg,
which is the group velocity.
That's the conclusion
which I would like
to draw from this exercise.
And this thing is actually
cosine omega0t minus K0x.
Therefore, this is
actually a harmonic wave.
The carrier is a harmonic
wave travelling at Vp equal
to omega0 divided by K0.
That's the kind of
conclusion which I would like
to draw from this exercise.
Any questions about what
we have discussed so far?
OK, then really you have to
hold tight and follow me really,
100% focus, because
this is actually
a complicated calculation.
So now what I can do is, now I
need to express my fs in terms
of C. So I do integration
from minus infinity
to infinity, d omega, C omega,
exponential minus i omega t.
So basically I can
write my f of s
in a functional form,
which we introduced before.
Then my f function is actually
equal to fs times exponential i
omega minus i omega0t.
So that's actually
what we defined there.
And this would be equal to
minus infinity to infinity.
I do this integration number,
omega C omega exponential minus
i omega plus omega0 times t.
So there's nothing special, I
just take my expression for fs,
multiply that by
exponential minus i omega0t.
Then that's actually what I get.
So since this is actually
integration over omega
from minus infinity to
infinity, therefore I
can always have the freedom
to shift the origin.
So that means f of t can be
returned as minus infinity
to infinity d omega C omega
minus omega0 exponential minus
i omega t.
Then we can see that is
fix a relation between C
of the f function, and
the C of the fs function.
So so far, everything is exact.
I haven't made any
approximation so far.
So now, I can take this function
and propagate that to all x.
In other words, I
can now take this ft,
and write down the psi
as a function of x and t.
So that means all the
different components are
traveling at different speeds.
So basically, I
can write it down
like d omega C omega minus
omega0, exponential minus i
omega t, exponential ikx.
Kx k is actually a
function of omega.
Any questions?
So that's actually just
identical to what we actually
have done before.
So now I can go from f of t to
sine, if you are following me.
So until here, everything exact.
You have all the
problems you have,
like you know this
dispersion essentially,
because all the
little components,
as you can see here, can be
travelling at different speeds.
So now, what I could
do is that if I
assume that C omega is only
sizable at the small range
around, it's only
sizable around omega0.
If now I take this
assumption and propagate
into this formula, then
I can write this psi
function roughly
like minus infinity
to infinity d omega C omega
minus omega0 exponential minus
i omega t exponential i.
Now I can take the
formula which I actually
did an approximation,
around omega0.
Around omega0, K can be returned
us omega over Vg plus b.
This is actually where I
take the approximation.
Only consider the first order
in the Taylor expansion.
So you can see now here,
it's not exact anymore.
But now I write approximate
function of form for K omega.
So what I'm going to
get is omega over Vg
plus b, multiplied by x.
Any questions?
Now I have the approximation.
And of course now I can gather
all the terms related to omega
together.
I'm getting minus
infinity to infinity
d omega C omega minus omega0
exponential minus i omega t
minus x over Vg,
exponential ibx.
So basically, I am merging
this term and that term.
This term and that term
will give you this term.
And what is essentially the
rest is the exponential ibx.
We are almost there.
So now I would like to use this
board, so I need to erase that.
So now I continue from
here, and I can now again,
I can again change the origin
of this infinite integral
so that this can be
written as minus infinity
to infinity, d omega
C function of omega,
exponential minus i omega
plus omega0, t minus x divided
by Vg, and exponential ibx.
So what I come from this
board to that formula,
if you are following
me we are almost there,
because I am changing
the origin again,
so that omega minus
omega0 becomes
omega, become a new omega.
Is everybody
accepting this fact?
And that means
the original omega
will become omega plus omega0.
I'm trying to go really slow,
so that everybody can follow.
I hope you are following.
All right, then
now I can actually
redistribute, arrange
all those terms
and the magic will happen.
So that means rearrange
all those terms,
minus infinity to
infinity d omega C omega
exponential minus i
omega t minus x divided
by Vg, exponential minus i
omega0t, exponential i omega0
over Vg plus b x.
So basically, there's
really no magic.
What I'm doing is really to
rearrange all those terms,
so that this term is
actually rearranged
so that it's now omega
times t minus x over Vg.
It's an independent
exponential term.
And I actually extract this term
times t to be returned here.
I'm just rearranging things, OK?
I'm not changing anything.
And finally, I can merge
this term and that term,
and become this function field.
I can immediately recognize
that after this rearrangement,
this is just
re-writing the formula,
putting all those terms
in different place.
Of course, you can
actually review
this part of the lecture
in the lecture notes later.
But basically, we're not doing
anything fancy but rearranging
things over in different place.
Then I can actually
quickly identify
what I am trying to integrate.
So this integration
is over omega.
Therefore all those terms
are now related to omega.
Therefore, they are just some
terms which are sitting there,
they don't participate.
And if you focus on
this part, what is this?
If you compare that to the
original equation of which
I have here.
If you compare that to the
original fs equation here,
you can't immediately
identify that actually that's
a function of fs.
Originally this function
fs is a function of t.
And I'm going to that board now.
This is actually fs
with t minus x over Vg.
Surprisingly simple.
Now let's look at the right
hand side, this mass here.
This is actually K0, which
actually you cannot see
anymore.
It's in the back of this board.
And then if you combine
these two terms,
basically what you
get is exponential
minus i omega0t minus K0x.
So look at what we have done.
I got started with this
Fourier transform functional
form of fs.
I multiplied fs
by cosine omega0t
and go to the complex notation.
It becomes exponential
minus i omega0t.
If I multiplied that, I get my
f function, which is like this.
You get additional term there.
I rearrange things
and change the origin,
and I can rewrite ft in
this functional form.
And I can have a relation
between the C related to fs
to the C related to f of t.
I propagate ft over
the full space,
and attain my sine, which is
the amplitude as a function
of place and the time.
Until here, everything is exact.
Then I have
introduced assumption,
which is C of omega is only
sizable, only contributing,
around omega zero, therefore
I can do approximation form
for the K function, which
is this functional form.
Then I just do the integration.
Then I found that, interesting!
This side is-- you
should be taking
the real part of this thing.
This side have two components.
The first component
is fs, which is
the original signal you put in,
the signal you want to send.
It's actually progressing at
the speed of group velocity.
So now you understand what
this group velocity means.
That's the speed
of the signal you
want to send in the AM radio.
And this thing is
actually modulated
by exponential function,
which is actually
the propagating at the speed
of Vp, equal to omega0 over K0.
So the carrier still,
after you actually
include many, many
terms contracting
the f function, the sine
which is the amplitude,
the trick is that only the
omega value around omega0
contributes.
If that happen, then
you can see that there
are two structures
actually propagating
at different speeds, and that
you can actually understand
the structure independently.
That means your signal
will not be distorted
if you're sending it this way.
But the difference
is that the speed
of the signal you are
sending is actually
at the speed of group velocity.
That is actually
the amazing fact
which actually enables
us to send signal
over thousands and thousands
of miles away from the source.
So what is actually
done is actually that,
suppose you have some
kind of radio station.
You can send the radio, and the
radio will go over the place,
and got refracted
by atmosphere--
the atmosphere on Earth.
Got refracted, and the receiver
from some place which is really
distant from the
source can still
see it without any
dispersion, as we show here.
And it's actually
going to be propagating
at the speed of group velocity.
So you may not
actually believe that.
How about we do a
simulation like what
we did before with MIT wave?
So this is actually the
example which we did last time.
We have an nit wave.
We can compose that
into many, many pieces.
And then see how it evolved
as a function of time.
This is actually
without dispersion,
therefore everything is perfect.
So now I would like to
introduce some excitement there.
If I have dispersion, like
0.1, alpha is equal to 0.1,
and see will happen.
Then just a reminder that
things will not go super well.
Wait a second, what am I doing?
This is actually still
without dispersion.
Sorry for that.
It should be--
OK, so let's take a look
at the triangular case.
This is now with dispersion.
And you can see that as a
reminder as a function of time,
the shape of the signal
which you would like to send
is actually changing
as a function of time.
And after a few
thousands of miles,
you will not even recognize the
original structure we put in.
So that's the trouble
we are actually facing.
You can see that it's getting
wider and wider et cetera.
So now what will happen if
I send this kind of signal.
This is a signal which you
have some kind of shape.
You can imagine that there's
sounds kind of analogue.
And I am now doing the
calculation to actually map
all the individual components.
And now I'm going to
propagate through the median.
And the blue is the original
non-dispersive median
situation.
And the red is actually
the propagation
in a dispersive median.
You can see the propagation
in a dispersive median
is faster, because alpha is
actually larger than one--
larger than zero.
So it's actually, in
this case it's 0.1.
And you can see that the red
cosine omega0t modulated signal
is progressing, and the shape
of the analogue is not changing.
You can see that, right?
So it's very different from
what we actually see before
with a single triangular pulse.
Now you can see that, ha!
Only when n gets
very large, I start
to be able to feed all
those little structures.
That means the end value, or say
the omega value, which I need
is you really narrow,
a very narrow range,
which will actually match
with what we have been doing.
And now I start to
propagate all those things.
And you can see that the red
is actually traveling faster
than the blue, which
is what we expect.
And you can see
now, in the instance
they actually
overlap each other,
you can see that envelope,
the shape of the envelope,
is still the same.
It's exactly what
we actually printed.
And that actually brings me
to the end of my lecture.
We have on understood how
the AM radio actually works.
And next time, we
are going to talk
about uncertainty principles.
What the hell?
What happened?
And believe me,
they are actually
connected to each other.
Uncertainty principle is
actually highly related
to wave and the vibrations.
Thank you very much, and let me
know if you have any questions.